all right
this is a work session so we don't need
a quorum which is nice
um we'll start off very quickly with the
pledge
um representative Phillips you're
joining us would you like to do the
projected loose and the plush thing
okay
um I do expect today's work session to
be probably our shorter one out of the
ones we're going to have I'm only
planning on having about two more of the
work sessions and then two more field
sessions uh and then the game plan will
be to reconvene the subcommittee either
once or twice before the filing deadline
um so we can kind of do our our last big
push of things that we think we can
agree on
um and maybe things that we can't agree
on but we should try anyways from the
respective sides
um so the next two work sessions though
the next one will be about
um will be the content from the study
committee that we retained that was part
of the deal pertaining it so obviously
operating in faith we will then do that
um I believe representative O'Neill is
looking into a field session for us
um a field listening session for Us in
Manchester I believe she's taking point
on that she didn't message me about it
um she asked what the parameters were
and I said Wednesday at 5 30 anywhere in
Manchester
um so those are her parameters she can't
be here today
um today's subjects is the granted steps
for Quality program
um and then the one that I know is going
to be the most contentious which is the
child care ratios
so I want to start off with the grant
steps for Quality program
um and kind of what I have heard
um in my experience with it which is
that it it appears that it is not
serving well I would start off with I
think there is some confusion as to what
its function is supposed to be
um so my understanding is that it's
function obviously the function is to
increase the quality care for child care
in the state of New Hampshire
um it's literally the name right
um the the issue is I believe some
providers are looking at it as a if I do
this this will be a monetary gain for me
and I think that's where the disconnect
is happening
um I think our friend Jen sent us a very
well well done document I believe we've
all read that
um basically outlining how if you enter
into the quality steps for Care Program
you'll actually lose money as a provider
um so I think that's
for the committee that's probably the
number one place that we should look at
is if providers are going to enter into
that program
um they shouldn't be doing so at a
financial loss
um so it is a I believe it's a federally
backed program so there are some pretty
big guard rails on it it's my
understanding
um so if anybody wants to get up and
speak to that
um I'd be happy to hear from them their
experiences with it I was hoping Jim
would be here because she obviously but
she's not so anybody like to DHHS you
want to give and talk about gsq
foreign
for the record
good morning my Karen Hebert
economic stability at DHHS
and I am happy to provide information
about gsq at a very high level I think
it's important for the committee to know
that at this time
we are
initiating a more formal comprehensive
evaluation of gsq so that we would be
able to address any recommendations
within that and make adjustments to the
system
uh it'll probably take a little bit of
time to do that we have a procurement
that's ongoing right now we should be
bringing that to GNC by the end of June
uh with a contract and part of that
procurement includes some of the
evaluation components that we want but
we will be expanding that quite broadly
so we're just initiating that now and I
think that it's important
um that we take everything into
consideration about this particular
system we all want a quality system but
I think that you are correct that it is
focused on quality and the funding that
is attached to gsq was never intended to
cover any and all expenses of what it
may take to bring a provider up to a
certain standards so that we would all
like to see
but it is it does provide some funding
in order to incentivize
the providers to be able to do that so
although it's a smaller amount of money
that is the intent behind it but it has
never been to fund the entire quality
system for folks
um
so I guess I would ask the committee
that you know we have the opportunity to
conduct this evaluation I'd be happy to
report back on that it will likely take
several months
um but we currently have over 80
providers in the system now so we want
to make sure that they are able to
continue within that process and not
disrupt what it is that they're doing we
have about I think another 30 who have
recently applied so it is growing but
the the procurement that I mentioned
earlier is also intended so that it
would provide guidance and assistance
and support for providers in entering
onboarding into the system and also
throughout the system with things like
coaching and assessments uh also other
funding opportunities for them to reach
these standards that we are wanting to
reach
specific questions I definitely have
some um some cover I just want to convey
um things that I have heard I I'm glad
you're evaluating it I knew it was I'd
heard it was getting revisions some of
the concerns that we had
heard was that providers that were
currently in the system weren't aware of
changes that were happening
um and there was a I would say quite
considerable amount of frustration
expressed to the committee about that
um so that's the political way of
putting that
um so I guess my message to you guys as
you're doing your due diligence
um
is you know be aware that the providers
that are in there are very precariously
watching to make sure that the goal post
is not getting moved I will say we heard
in Conway one of the frustrations was
that the goal post was being moved to be
easier to hit and they had hit a farther
away goal post
um and they didn't think that that was
um I think Fair
I don't know if that's the proper way to
look at that just speaking personally
um I think it's more of a statement of
um
you know is the is the program headed in
the right direction if they go close for
moving away from them that would be
that would be a whole other story but if
it's moving it closer you know it's fine
um can you talk about you said you in
junior bringing a procurement to
governor and Council can you talk about
what that procurement entails um sure I
would like to also respond to your
comments about the providers who have
expressed some concerns we met with that
group a couple of weeks ago myself uh
commission associate commissioner Chris
santanello and the president of the
child care advisory Council Marianne
barter we met at the governor's office
with the governor's office about those
concerns and we did come up with a
particular agreement with them about
moving forward that does include this
comprehensive evaluation so we've heard
what they've had to say and are we're
taking steps that includes suspending
portions of it for those who who are
having some struggles with or challenges
with understanding
what it is that's expected
I think that it's clear there's a
disconnect somewhere because well we
have a number of providers who are
completely engaged in this system and
it's effective for them we are obviously
seeing a number of providers that is not
so effective and they have a lot of
questions very valid questions and we
are taking the opportunity to address
that we're currently taking steps to
expand an advisory committee that's been
in place for gsq for for several months
so I think that where you know the the
program feels like it's been
communicating effectively with people
but apparently not everybody is
understanding so where is the disconnect
we need to identify that and make sure
that everybody is clear so that advisory
committee we're looking at expanding it
so that it includes a more broader
representation of the provider community
and I'm sorry NRP you said the provider
community
so
um they were very pleased the providers
that we met with with the governor's
office with the conditions that we put
in place they seem to be satisfied with
that and we're going to be meeting with
them again we'll invite them to the
advisory committee once we have
broadened that committee I'm in
preparing a charter at this time in
order to put the parameters in place for
what that should look like and it'll be
very visible we will make sure that
the information and minutes that come
out of that particular meeting are
available for public viewing
I I do know that one of their
um it sounds like you've addressed it
one of their complaints was that
providers weren't properly represented
that was their complaint I'm just
conveying that
um so I'm glad I'm excited delayed
delighted to hear that as a provider
myself
um and then the other one the other
complaint that they had had once again
I'm just relaying the complaints so
don't don't shoot the messenger I have
plenty of people in Concord already
trying to do that to me
um
the uh
the the other complaint that they had
was that the people who were on the
board for gsq The Advisory Board
um were not a part of any of the changes
that were proposed so can you kind of
address that complaint that we have
heard is there any validity to that
obviously I'm I'm new to this realm uh
the side of the gsq so um I I'm not I'm
not leveling the accusation I just once
again bringing the message forward is
there validity to that statement are
they out of their mind um like what's
going on that's a great question so uh
and it's difficult for me to speak on
behalf of that particular group and what
it is other than what I've heard myself
from them directly in what they did not
understand about the revisions that were
being made yet on the other hand I have
an advisory committee and the program
that is basically stating we have
informed everyone we have uh we're
available for we've provided office
hours we've provided a lot of
information over a long period of time
about what it is that this system is
going to look like including some of the
enhancements that were
deployed in March of 23. so
that there's one you know part of this
that we feel that we are communicating
but then it's not quite being understood
by recipients and I think that
um their concerns are are fair and valid
and I think we just need to address them
which were in that process of doing it
it sounds like we're headed to the right
just what you're saying it sounds like
we're headed in a better path than where
we were I'd say even maybe two or three
weeks ago
um
so that's that was the whole point of
having today was the complaints we had
heard two or three weeks ago so it
sounds like we are um we're moving the
right path the fact that there's not
many of them here today probably tells
me that they may suddenly believe that
um representative page can you talk can
you talk to me about how this was
communicated to your participants
I think you know what I'm hearing is
that there's a lot of effort to
communicate but when people are not
understanding to me that's an indication
that maybe the way it's being
communicated is not how they need to
receive it if this seems to be
you know so I just I want to make sure
we're not saying that the providers are
not understanding and getting it how are
we not communicating to them effectively
so what do we need to change so that
this doesn't recur and that's something
we need to really take a closer look at
so I know that there's been a great deal
of email communication to the provider
Community we've certainly
um you know open it up for office hours
so to speak for people to call when they
have questions we receive a lot of calls
from providers asking specific questions
about the gsq so we take the time to be
able to explain to them what we find I
think is that perhaps the guide is a
little bit overwhelming
to people so there's a very
comprehensive guide that's out there now
plus the revisions
plus a a third guide on the incentives
and how that works so I think that it's
so much information perhaps it's too
much information that people are just
not being able to and I think from the
provider's perspective as well of course
folks behind me can speak more to that
but I think that
you know when you have so much
information and and since covid
providers are really struggling as you
probably have heard trying to just
maintain
uh their their business trying to grow
trying to move forward and away from
covid which has been very very
challenging with Workforce issues
so in light of that I think having to
take the time to sit down and read a
multi-page guide never mind three of
them is probably a lot to ask so I know
that we get a lot of questions from
providers about what information that's
already in the guide which tells me that
people are probably not reading it
thoroughly enough they don't have time
they don't have the ability to just
schedule that and manage their business
at the same time I get that
um so how can we share the information a
little bit differently and I think that
we need to incorporate that into an
evaluation that includes that provider
input it's beyond input this is a
partnership so we need to be able to
make sure that we have that open
communication because when we do have
people that don't understand it then
obviously we have a product that isn't
effective
it was not effective nobody's going to
win so while we have some groups that
they do understand it and they're moving
forward with it why is it that some do
and some don't so a lot of questions
around this and not a lot of answers yet
um you said your testimony that
um March 23rd you guys rolled out
enhancements
can you outline some of those
is that two is that two in the gritty I
can well you know maybe in the
nitty-gritty I'd be happy to provide you
with a copy of that I don't think that's
a lengthy document but it basically
um puts in place uh additional coaching
opportunities
um ability to be on some leadership
tracks
again I have to pull up the document
which I can just send you if that's easy
but yeah that's fine I'd like to see
that um you know because it goes into
the whole
um communication and what's going on
um I do think in general you said
there's 80 providers in there there's 30
providers coming on board that's 110
um and there's 529 licenses in the state
of New Hampshire
um so you're looking at less than 20
adoption rate
um
I guess probably the one thing I would
disagree on is I don't think that that's
so awesome
um that's less than one out of five
um
and part of the reason is that people
aren't adopting this in my opinion is
that they don't
they don't need from a business
perspective you don't need to do this
right because the demand the demand and
Supply are so out of whack right that
this doesn't this doesn't give you a leg
up in acquiring parents because
acquiring acquiring parents and students
is easy
um so I think I think to the program's
credit that's one of the reasons it's
like it rolled out like the exact wrong
time
um we had a huge Market imbalance
so I I am kind of um
I I am kind of curious as that number I
said I do I do just respectfully
disagree that 110 you know 80 right now
30 potential
um is not a um
I I would say acceptable uptake for
what's supposed to be Quality Care
um I do look at this program as kind of
like enhanced industry standards which
may be a better way of uh putting it in
a business term
so you know I think I was I was a little
hesitant to bring this subject up for
this committee because it does slightly
fall outside of what I would call our
scope our scope being increasing access
to Affordable and Safe Care
um because this is literally quality
Care
um but that being said it's the reason
one of the reasons the program's not
being taken up is because there's not
access to any care
um that's my that's my opining on the
program What's the total uh monetary
allocation for the program
what it costs to run gsq
what's it what's allocated from the
budget
um I mean what's it I mean it's not
budgets from the feds but that's a great
question and I think I'd have to look
that up to be able
to okay if he gets that too
um
budgeting is done for this year but it's
something for uh
it's something for I mean it's we're
required
um to expand
sent of our federal funding from the
child care Development Fund specifically
for Quality activities of which this is
including but I can get you more
specific yeah that would be great
because it's like 26 million or 36
million dollar fund I cannot remember
that is 36 or 38 I'll have to look that
up
an extra 40. so it's 36 and a 40 all
right so nine percent of 36 million or
96 or 40 million so roughly just under
four million dollars doing the uh
that back of the envelope map
yeah yeah it's yeah but that's what we
use so that's what DHS has to use the
nine percent and we're using it to the
gsq to qualify for the nice for the
block grant okay so just to get back to
your other question with respect to the
procurement
um just in a again a high level summary
this is basically to assist the
department to help with the engagement
and supportive programs in their
continuous quality improvements
um the uh
um it includes a number of things the
scope is pretty broad but it's basically
in order to
um on board
staff help them with understanding the
financial incentives and how that works
uh connecting them with perhaps other
resources
process and impact
conducted an impact evaluation which I
explained that we would want to broaden
it includes a validation study it would
also be for the coordination and
provision of professional development
activities for programs and staff
as I mentioned onboarding it's support
for programs developing additional
system endorsements they would be able
to create a pathway if you will for the
different
for the two uh choices that they have
for either
going by the pathway for an
environmental rating system or using the
pyramid model so they the the
procurement will be that the vendor will
help us create those Pathways uh and for
just further support for people
conducting any Readiness checks
further guidance
expanding online access to the
professional developments modules and
other courses that are available
so it's pretty comprehensive
representative page
could the committee get a copy of the
scope of work sure this I think that
would be helpful to us
yes representative Christian
um one of the other things that we heard
from a few of the providers I think in
Conway
um was that with some of the changes
they said that they like suddenly needed
to go take a new program and then
weren't able to find it online have you
heard anything about that or maybe
materials that need updating so the
links are going to the correct places or
was that a misunderstanding that there's
a concern with with online links I guess
I I think so or they said that they
needed to go take
um you know some kind of quiz or
assessment or something oh yeah thanks I
think this followed the March
updates
um that folks were had planned their
schedule to go in and you know do do the
work to on the next step
came in and Mark saw the updates had
been made and that certain modules that
they needed to do in order to proceed
would not be available till the fall so
they of course had planned their whole
schedule these updates were made they
were not you know felt not in the loop
um so that was the the comment you know
that's that's the provider's perspective
on that situation but that was the the
situation that that provider described
sure and they did provide us that
information during our meeting with the
governor's office okay
um
so maybe this is already part of the
scope of work but I'd love more Outreach
to folks who are not participating to
understand what their barriers are to
participation I think one of my big
concerns
I think we can all stand behind the goal
of uh improving quality
my concern is who has the means to
participate
and so who gets to achieve that quality
improvement so if we say one-fifth of
the state is moving down this quality
pathway four-fifths or not who is that
four-fifths and who ends up underserved
so I would really like to get a handle
on how can we make this more equitable
um you know I know that this that some
centers in my area are participating and
feeling very stretched by that others
are not I've also heard of folks who are
making decisions in order to participate
like ending their Aftercare you know
um so we're in order to achieve quality
they're reducing capacity right that's
not what we want exactly so I think
um you know that a lot of my concerns
are around that piece I think
you know great like pyramid model great
love it let's move folks down that
pathway but who isn't who isn't able to
participate and how do we ensure that
that we can get those adoption numbers
up so I would hope that in that scope of
work
we're looking we're taking a hard look
at that as well just putting that out
that's a very valid point
um so you touched on one of the things
that in this um GNC procurement uh
something that I have said
um is an interest of mine that I hope we
can get to for this committee which is
expanding the access to online trainings
right
um so one of my dreams to come out of
this committee is to get it to where the
state of New Hampshire is providing
teachers with a pathway to a CDA for
free
um and that's coming from me
so put that put that in your um put that
in your pocket uh the reason I say that
is because
um if we have this money available and
it can be used towards that and that's
an increase in the quality of a teacher
right a CDA is increasing the quality of
a teacher right
um that would be something that I'd like
the department to look at because we're
going to look at it in here because one
of the issues that we have to do to
solve the long-term supply problem is
get more people to be lead teachers and
the CDA at least in my experience the
CDA is in which the vast majority of my
teachers qualify to be a Lead Teacher
plus obviously there are thousand hours
of experience which is about six months
um
but that would be something that
um would accomplish the other long-term
dream that I have which is getting
people out of high school ready to be a
Lead Teacher within six months of
graduating high school
um so can is that part of that process
can you can you take a look to see if
that's a thing I know we already offer
CTE to begin with
um
various professional development
opportunities uh what specifically
they're for what the credentials are for
we're also in the process of preparing
to adopt rules for those credentials
um so
it really really or
um you know birth through age 13 so that
may limit your dream I'm not sure but
it's only a dream if you have it
um
it's I I do believe and I've said before
and I've said it in public interviews
um you know there's short-term they're
short-term medium-term and long-term
problems that we have to fix this body
has to fix obviously the supply the
supply issue is the number one issue and
I do view as a medium-term solution is
getting the state especially they're
already offering CTE online
um and the cdas are by and large already
offered online I think they're like four
or five hundred bucks per individual
which is not nothing but it's not
let's be honest it's not going to
bankrupt anybody either
um not the state I mean not going to
pick up the state I should say
um so if if we could find a way while
this program is being
arguably underutilized
um and about to go over an enhancement
if there's a way to dovetail that in
there that would be amazing and would
stop me from having to go to my
political bosses and say Hey I want X
millions of dollars to develop a program
so that people can go and become a
teacher A Lead Teacher and then we can
have all the providers of the CDA come
out and Lobby against it and
have that nasty Throwdown fight let me
just provide you with a list and then if
you would kindly let me know if you see
what you're looking for on that
um or not yeah I I would I would yeah
that's what I'm specifically looking for
is a way to get more people qualified as
Lead Teacher through the CDA so that
that's that's literally exactly what I'm
looking for
uh because that is the um
you know they require these teachers are
every teacher is required to a certain
amount of CTE
um I see no why I see no reason why an
assistant teacher and Associate teacher
couldn't have as part of the required
CTE pursuing their CDA so they become a
Lead Teacher so they can make more money
and then expand so they're they're
they're expanded right because they're
now making you know anywhere from two to
four dollars an hour more which is a big
raise
um and then on top of that we are
increasing the supply of allowable child
care and say New Hampshire because the
number one Supply issue occurs in the
lead teacher position which you are
required to have in every classroom
there's the vision
all right so there's my dream said out
loud I guess not so quietly
um I think we're approaching into this
this uh by the way thank you so much for
just
sitting at that stage in the hot seat
and having all those questions fired at
you
um is any is anyone else from the
committee have any other um of things uh
for her on gsq
all right well that will give you a
breather
um thank you so much again thank you
thank you
um does anyone else wish to get up and
speak to gsq
foreign
state your name for the record
hi I'm Marianne barter I'm the chair of
the New Hampshire Child Care advisory
Council and the New Hampshire Child Care
advisory Council has been involved in
the Q the gsq system since the beginning
we have been part of this very very
lengthy decision-making process it was
like 10 years in the making it was an
incredibly long period And I would like
to say that the mistakes that were made
are probably very human mistakes we
rolled it out at the wrong time this was
a terrible time to roll it out and I
wonder if the response would have been
different if it had been rolled out in
2018 but the document looked different
in 2018. so I do think there has been a
responsiveness to Providers
um I think the timing was poor and I
also think moving forward it's really
important to have a quality document
because it looks like more and more
Federal funding will be coming to States
through the the QRS system the quality
rating system so that's hugely important
to get this right I think for the child
care advisory Council really our biggest
push will be for decision making
abilities so right now the
decision-making ability lies with DHHS
and that's a huge benefit for Doh DHHS
but it's also a barrier too because they
are in the hot seat when things like
this happen when things happen go badly
with the system so what we'd like to do
is work in Partnership to make sure that
we move on to a consensus or at least a
majority rule so that the next levels
that come out will have great provider
input will have great state input and
we'll come out with something that's
really a workable document
all right I want to dig into that
because that was a bit of a bombshell
hidden up there
um you just asked for you basically just
asked for rule making Authority yeah
yeah oh sorry not necessarily rule
making Authority I apologize but I I
didn't say I didn't say the answer was
no
you'll apart that
um so let's let's let's back all that up
um because I'm not at least speaking
personally I'm not entirely opposed to
that I'm sure DHS would probably have
something to say about that
um but that's okay that's why this is a
political system and that's why we solve
political differences
um
so
there's the QRS system which is where
the feds are Doling the money out of
um and you are you are the child care
advisory Council yes
which is go ahead and
um I I I know of you but just for
everybody else here go ahead and
elaborate on the child care advisory
Council and the role that you wish it to
play in the gsq in the QRS system
so we're a legislatively enacted body
and we have voting and non-voting
members made up of child care providers
State leaders
um there's
um people who receive child care
services they are on the committee and
really what we do is we are supposed to
inform on anything that will
impede the access and affordability of
child care in the state of New Hampshire
my brain is flaring
um so uh you said you are to inform on
basically new things happening with
child care
who do you inform and we tell DHHS we
have a report that we issue every year
that goes to the house oversight
committee we reported on that in April I
believe April yeah in conjunction with
DHHS and that's a really long process we
get asked a lot of questions of that
um
but that it's state leaders it can be
the governor we we're really can inform
to anyone and they can take that and
they can read it and they can do it they
can hope they can frame it put on the
wall but they don't have to actually do
anything with it nope
although I will say in the past our
reports tend to lead to legislation so
we've had lots of opportunities in the
past be part of the legislative process
yeah
um
so this is an idea as you know and I've
advocated from this seat before I
personally believe that providers and
and
teachers and they basically take
government put it over here put
everybody else is affected by government
over here I feel like these people over
here do not have equal say an input into
this process
um that that's not a question that's
just my personal feelings
um
I have envisioned a world
um where this group over here has equal
Authority or even a negative a negative
political Authority on the people over
here yeah yeah I have the same vision
yes we do have a version of that in
government already in my other hat
wearing election law uh in election law
we have this thing called the ballot law
Commission which is a legislative and
active body composed of I think they
have they have five people and four
alternates
um and they get to decide things
um so yeah I think it's something for
this committee to consider given that we
already have this legislative and active
body that is composed of providers and
other interested parties
um I wouldn't give you rule making
Authority that would be a little too
much
um but maybe a negative rule-making
Authority
um might be something for the body to
consider especially if it's coming from
the legislator that way we don't have to
perform things like special committees
in the future or read the rule 62
document that 52 document that comes out
every Friday
um and wonder if we have to go to uh
jowcar uh to to stop something bad from
happening
um so anyways that's it sounds like we
should have served English on that I
started to interrupt you um I just
wanted to touch on that while you you
allowed that grenade out there I've been
thinking it but you said out loud so I
want to be honest about the limitations
of child care
are a couple of child care programs but
sometimes the chair is a state employee
sometimes the chair may be a parent so
um it's a very Democrat I I think it's a
very Democratic group we never go out
and say that we are support or against
anything without talking to the group
without getting a feel for um you know
for example ratios will be something I
don't have a great answer to that yet as
child care advisory Council but after
June 8th I will because that's our next
meeting I'm sure so um but I just wanted
to be aware of kind of the limitations
of our
I don't think that's a limitation that's
what that's how political bodies work
um
that's that's one of the uh it's one of
the advantages you have is having a
chair who has a degree in political
philosophy which is totally and utterly
worthless except for this specific
situation
all right so that's your guys's take on
QRS the rulemaking
um if you had any changes I assume you
guys as a body you're going to make
suggestions on how to uh overhaul gsq
um I assume that's a public document so
we don't need to Hash that out right now
I imagine
um because you're going to do that as
you're moving forward I am fully
confident that we are going to come out
with a document that serves our needs
um all right with that with that uh as
they say and talk here with that on that
bombshell uh does anybody else have any
other questions comments concerns for
the uh just for the hearing nope all
right anybody else wish to get up and
speak to gsq
foreign
I hope I'm the first one to ever make a
Top Gear reference in a New Hampshire
hearing
good morning I'm Jackie Cowell from
Early Learning New Hampshire
um we're a Statewide non-profit
representing
um both the interests of child care
providers as well as the families they
serve
um so I think
um one thing that you know Marianne I
got a quick question for you as you're
walking out
um
so on the you know when you read the RSA
for the led the legislatively enacted
Child Care advisory Council there is a
seat for a representative
um appointed by the speaker of the house
and there is a seat for state senator uh
Senator Becky Whitley's just been
appointed to it but I don't think
there's a state rep at this point is
there
oh great okay that wouldn't make sense
it does make sense even though she's on
the opposite party that would probably
be my pick too 25 years of child care
hard to uh
hard to look that down yeah so anyway I
just wanted to point that out but um so
so in our capacity of early learning New
Hampshire we've been sitting on the um
qris gsq for years you know almost over
a decade as well the task force and so
it really
um I am very pleased that you know
you're looking at it but the fact that
there is this process with DHHS now
where there's going to be a revisit a
revision together that they will change
the advisory I think they also meet
quarterly which you know again maybe
they'll be meet more frequently really
um the per so I used to sit on it for
almost a decade and then not one member
of our team Chris casterly from
Rochester
um Child Care at the time was pointed to
it for us
um and her her feedback really to me has
been it's more
they're not really acting as an advisory
Council they get on Zoom and they're
told things and then the meeting ends so
I think that's something that's going to
be good to take a look at you know I
know that I feel confident DHHS will
take that seriously and figure it out
and I loved your question about you know
how are we communicating let's evaluate
what really sinks in what people hear
and in terms of money
um in two I believe it was the budget
session of 2017. it might be might have
been 2019 I'll have to go back but
Governor sununu put in six million
dollars for at that time the qris system
um with the idea there was two million
in year one and six million in year two
knowing it would go up to eight million
governor sununu was on board with there
being an eight million dollar allocation
from state government for qris at that
time it didn't pass it was put into hb2
and it got taken out it didn't happen
but governor sununu was on board with
that and there was a really good formula
of how to get to 8 million now it's true
that people's full costs aren't covered
but a lot of them were you know there
were 250 I might be it might be 230.
people in the QRS system back then
230 were either license plus or
accredited those are the two 32 or 30 um
programs
providers right
250 I believe it's almost half yeah and
so um it really was this idea of being
partners with the state going over and
above licensing you know for the benefit
of the program and the families and the
kids of course number one but they were
willing to do it because it was
reasonable and they were a big part of
developing it so in 2019 right before
the pandemic hit you know a lot of us
were we were in brown Auditorium talking
about the ideas people were really
excited about the changes then the
pandemic hit then it all came out and it
was different
and so you know I think from the
provider's perspective so again really
glad that we're looking at this I was I
think the 80 if you really dig deep into
the 80 a lot of them are already
accredited or there are they're sort of
coming into the system automatically as
a Head Start program Macy's got him
halfway there you know they didn't have
to do a lot of different things so so
I'm glad and that's basically all I
wanted to share with you and thank you
any questions
all right I think we've uh anyone else
wish to speak to you uh Grant steps for
Quality I do think Cora hoppy from
Rochester's on her way or she's here
she's walked in behind you I saw her
she was hiding from me she's one of my
favorite people
oh I know I'm everywhere I appreciate
you guys
welcome if you could say your name for
the record absolutely absolutely
Coraline hoppy the extractor over at
Rochester
Trend to me uh I am here for the quality
steps of success
um Granite States
thank you um right now we're licensed
plus so we're starting to integrate into
the system
um we have a huge staff we have 94
employees with us for us to get step two
into the system it's an incredible
amount of work I just recently got my
credentials done and we're going through
about 50 full-time staff so the process
is very daunting just to even begin to
look at and then with the current
changes and losing license plus funding
attached to that it's terrifying because
we're not going to be ready to enter the
system by the December date so losing
thirty two thousand dollars of license
plus funding would be devastating at
this point to our agency because we're
looking at a 500 000 deficit this year
so based off of the grant fundings year
prior and shrinking back down like it in
wages increasing so right now turnover
is extremely big like we have 10
Workforce people leaving two full-time
position three on maternity leave and a
bunch of high schoolers normally
turnover is okay I can handle that going
into summer but I am losing 10 and I
have to shrink my operating hours
because I can't without raising my rate
for my families be able to even
withstand our operation right now so
entering a system like this right now
while the industry is in chaos is just
going to set the system up for failure
and I'm with
DHHS I really want to partner and
collaborate and just already providers
are being pinned against parents I don't
want to have to be pinned up against
DHHS or even have my any funding taken
away so really just you know not so much
causing the system but looking at better
ways to integrate the system that we
currently have into another system
so I um I I just wanted to let you guys
know that I am here to help with that
and if you have any questions moving
forward to I can explain a little bit
more but entering the system right now
based off a three-year program like Jen
legere had given in her letter we're
looking at about two hundred thousand
dollars in cost so I can subsidize a
good chunk of that cost because we're
very fortunate because of our doe
program I'm already granted like brought
in grant funding for that so I don't
require the entire amount of funding to
come back I don't expect the state to
completely fund the quality but I can't
pass that cost onto my families because
currently our enrolled and we we have
enrollment turnover now we lose about
four weeks of Revenue every time we lose
a family and when two of my employees
left in their full-time staff they
looked at me and said the whole reason
we're leaving it's because it's like
watching families and children drowned
and we can't help them so we're already
subsidizing enough for these families
and child care providers so if we again
enter into a system right now that's
just not ready we're going to lose more
providers to a a quality system which we
we stand for we want to be quality and
we expect quality and
um but right now it's just not a good
time to enter into a completely new
system and keep changing it on us
so um I thank you guys and if you have
any questions sure um you're a private
call from our conversation uh you're a
non-profit provider right right correct
um can you elaborate on why you're
losing 32 000 oh well a good chunk of it
right now is the attendance space
um because of the stick and it you know
dealing with covet a lot of that
funding's taken away a lot of our
funding when we were doing on last
year's budget too was inflated so really
coming in this year to figure out a real
budget was hard and I'm a second year
executive director so really even with
accountants assistance Auditors
assistants we really inflated
um what we thought we were going to
bring in but not to be said we had had
huge surpluses last couple years so that
offset will be okay we're going to be
fine but if another agency is smaller
than ours takes a gigantic hit like that
they're not going to make it we will
because we're strong and we have great
community support and we're getting
upgrades to buildings that are being
funded through the city as a private
provider they don't get accessing to
that kind of funding so I'm seeing a
deficit because of poor estimation and
enrollment turnover and attendance base
versus enrollment based and um and
because we lose it in December if we
don't enter into the system
we're being cut off from our funding
you want to speak to that one
it's all right
Cora I'm sorry right if she answers that
question yeah absolutely it's called
Eugene Tom I'm still you guys know why I
scheduled this at 10 am because I am not
up at nine
thank you
so our meeting with the governor's
office one of the items that we did
agree upon was that
um
although we are aiming to continue with
gsq as the quality rating information
system
um while we conduct the evaluation while
we go through all this process we are
going to continue licensed plus so I
hope that's good news for you Cora I
found you 32 000 look at me all right
let's go home
so I mean for those who you know are in
that because we want to be able to
address things fairly I think that was
part of the decision that we want to be
able to continue that for now
we don't want people in both systems
because that isn't fair
um so if you are currently a license
plus you want to stay there for now
um and we'll have more information as we
go along it will end at some point but
um
for now this is
really best for for everybody there you
go see look at that
all right good job DHS it was a gold
star for the day
um
if we want to bring her back up or
I think uh hey look your trip to Concord
was worth it
um would anyone else like to speak to
gsq before we um close this on down and
get to what I'm sure is going to be the
really unifying subject of ratios
all right uh with that I'm going to move
on to child care ratios
um I'll kind of briefly committee on the
research that I have done
um my my personal thought process on it
um and and and and we can go from there
um so let me start off with uh I am not
going to get supportive of any change to
any ratio system that would in any way
uh compromise the safety of a child so
let me start off with that so if before
somebody loves the bomb of it's going to
be dangerous
nobody's nobody on this board nobody on
this committee is going to do anything
that is dangerous
um that being said
um once again short-term middle term and
long-term solutions to the child care
supply crisis in state New Hampshire the
only short-term solution is to look at
the ratios
that's it that's the only thing that you
can do that we could literally change
tomorrow that would immediately increase
the supply of child care in state New
Hampshire
you might refute that statement that
there's nothing else that we could do
that would change it tomorrow
okay
yeah exactly just yes
um
so that's why I wanted to bring this
admittedly sensitive subject up because
short-term media term and long-term
Solutions so if you don't at least have
a good faith honest conversation about
the what I believe is the only potential
short-term solution doesn't mean it's a
forever Solution by the way
um you're short changing the process
so I don't have I I did go through and
look through what other states do and
specifically my work was based around
infant and toddler care because that is
where the particular crunch is based on
the ratios you cannot compare apples to
apples across all states because they
don't all use the same age bands but you
can get kind of an idea so from my
research New Hampshire falls pretty much
in the middle in terms of allowable
Child Care ratios for infants and
toddlers
so when you're dealing with specifically
infants right the four to one ratio
if you just go to Five to one will you
immediately increase Supply by 25 you've
also increased workload by 25 percent
25 well by the way there are some states
that do five to one
um it doesn't mean it's right for New
Hampshire it just means there are states
that do five to one so one of the things
that did intrigue me was what this
Commonwealth of Massachusetts does
um so the Commonwealth Massachusetts
starts with a I always forget how to
phrase this it's technically a higher
ratio but we would feel as a lower ratio
because one over three is technically
bigger than one over four math we'll
call it a lower ratio for the sake of
all being on the same page so they start
off with a one out of three infant Child
Care ratio
you wonder why childcare is more
expensive Massachusetts there you go
um the largest cost as a teacher you've
just reduced that teacher's productivity
by 25 right
um so that's a problem one of the things
that they do do that's interesting is
when they put new teachers into the room
right so that second teachers come into
that room that ratio can get increased a
little bit so it goes from one to three
to basically two uh two over
um seven right so what we would do in
New Hampshire if we had a one to three
ratio we would be two over six right in
Massachusetts they go to two over seven
they still don't get to where New
Hampshire is which at that point be two
over eight but it's an interesting
system that I found to propose as a
potential compromise of balancing safety
not burning out teachers not doing a
wholesale change that was my cryptic
message about wholesale change
representative page
um but would but would have an immediate
a potentially immediate impact on the
supply of child care and state of New
Hampshire so let's talk about what that
means for infant care in the state of
New Hampshire
it's a it's basically it's ratio it's
ratio plus teachers minus one that's if
you want to think about it ratio plus
teachers minus one so if you one out of
four would not change if you have one
teacher in there
Fork it four babies that does not change
that stays exactly how it is now
when that second teacher comes into that
room there's two teachers in that room
instead of going from two to eight right
we'd go to two to nine
not two to ten because that'd be one
that would be one to five but two to
nine
and you can keep going up that now these
inference rooms in my experience they're
not huge right so there's not 50
teachers in a room you're not gonna
exploding right I think the most I've
ever seen is like four teachers in an
infant room uh after that it's
not sure there are centers that do more
than four but
um that in my experience I'm not too
many it makes my experience so that is
what I wanted to
um throw out there as something that to
talk about and I know we won't bang on
it too much today because I I'm
springing on everybody but part of that
is I wanted to do my due diligence
before the naysayers came out and just
said no no no
um but I think people were expecting me
to come out and say we're gonna go to
one to five and I'm like no we're not
gonna go to one of five because that
that would be a little aggressive but I
do think there's a big difference
between increasing
25 and increasing 12 and a half percent
um and then that that rate of increase
actually decreases as you get more
teachers in there the biggest jump is in
that first new teacher
um so anyways that is what I'm exploring
um that would put us still kind of in
the middle
um we wouldn't be Mississippi I think
they were like one to six or something
um but we also wouldn't be where we are
now
um it would be an immediate wholesale
change
um here are the there are parts of it
that I do not like the parts that I do
not like is
it has a little bit of chronic cronyism
in it because if you don't have a room
that's licensed for more than eight you
can't take advantage of this right so
you're only really benefiting centers or
providers that have
the physical capacity to hold more than
eight so if they have done their due
diligence and set up a room to only hold
eight kids
this doesn't help them so all those
people will not benefit from that they
would only benefit from a wholesale
change assuming they're within the
confines of the fire code we heard a lot
about that
um
so that's one of the things I don't like
because anybody who follows me knows
that I hate the government picking
winners and losers
um it's just it's just not fair
um however we have to do something that
would help so this is something that I I
looked at in the short term
um I definitely want to look at it for
infants and toddlers specifically the
child care crunch is a little less felt
um in that three in age upgroup just
because the ratios
do get bigger there
and profit-based centers prioritize
those because that's where they make
their money they don't make the money on
infants and toddler cares um the infant
toddler care in the profit-based child
care model infinite toddler here in say
New Hampshire is all about getting them
into the three and up room where they do
start making money
um
so anyways that's my thought process
that was my initial when I want to talk
about ratios that's what I want to talk
about I gave it the name of dynamic
ratios if somebody has a better name for
it
um that's it but that's what I wanted to
talk about I think that's a ballot a um
a balance
questions comments concerns
and she missed the whole presentation
um
yes
you just sit there it's okay MJ
hi again I'm Jackie Cowell from Early
Learning New Hampshire
um so what were you thinking about with
toddlers so it's the same thing it's
plus one teachers it's uh yeah ratio
plus teacher is minus one the reason you
do the minus one is so that the
underlying value doesn't change gotcha
gotcha question um do you know what main
from you mentioned Massachusetts what
Maine and our and Vermont are as well I
just wondered about teachers Crossing
because they have too many kids yep um
so I I if I remember we were basically
this I want to say we were almost the
same as Maine oh thank you um I I looked
at all 50 states so I didn't just she's
got it look at that yes you want to ship
it around
thank you I can't read it with my eyes
but I don't have my glasses
you might be able to read it
yeah
and I was glad you mentioned burnout
because that was that was a concern is
that you know
I end up
with with teachers no worries
um so as it pertains to burnout
um because I knew this was going to be
an issue sure
um I I did my due diligence and I asked
my own teachers yeah what would you do
if right
um so I propose something I well I
didn't propose the dynamic ratio to them
because they didn't want to spend 30
minutes explaining it to them
um but what I did essay was how would
you feel if you took on specifically to
my infant teachers how would you feel if
you had if you had a fifth kid in this
room but I paid you 75 more a week
right the teacher would get paid more
because that's where you would put that
extra that's as a provider that's where
I would put it right
um because you just increased from a
profit from I can't speak for the
non-profit world I don't operate the
nonprofit world but in the profit world
right yeah we would we would reward that
work right right and you'd be amazed
they're like oh that sounds great
so I I you know you would if teacher
burnout the way I look at my broader
statement on teacher burnout is that it
is only a concern of the state if it any
which way compromises safety right if it
is about you know keeping teachers happy
or that sort of stuff that is a problem
of the provider that's the provider's
job and we see that with benefits and
hours and stability and all sorts of
other things right the the only in my
personal opinion the only time the state
is concerned is if it's a safety issue
so if the teacher is burned out and
that's creating a safety issue that's a
different story right if the teachers
burned out and you know
yeah they just have a glass of wine on
Friday night you know that's that's a
provider issue right
um so it is a it's but that's why we
have to talk about it right nothing's
nothing is set in stone sure and so we
did a we do oh they have the
Massachusetts system on here I'm not
crazy I am crazy just not in the street
right
and every two weeks or twice a month we
do a large Zoom call with the Child Care
Community I've mentioned it before about
100 or so providers show up and so we
did an independent poll knowing this
hearing was coming just really quickly
asking people and 73 they didn't want
did just said they did they weren't
looking to change ratios 27 said they
did so I think you know once you have a
real good clear proposal we can put it
back out and just see what the provider
Community I mean you know weighs in what
they're you know correct
um and you have to once again it's going
to be
each of those are going to be different
because if they have a you know if they
have a room that can only hold eight
they're not going to support going to
two to nine right because they're just
missing out
um but it's that's why I've held back on
this because I think everybody thought I
was just going to say increase the
ratios no other conversation but I'm
smarter than that Paige I'm smarter than
that
um
he says he's smarter than that he knows
I know what the opposition is going to
be you know part of being good in
politics is knowing your opposition is
going to say before they're going to say
it right
um yeah we were just trying to give you
information what the providers were
asking for yeah
um
any other things you'd like to apply any
questions
when is your next meeting pardon when
it's the next meeting yeah so you guys
are welcome to come it's the second and
fourth Thursdays of the month from 1 to
2 30 on Zoom
except for the child care advisory
Council which it takes the uh for the
second second
um Thursday in the even months so the
next one coming up is June 8th next week
that's the child care advisory where
voting members are required to be in
person and the rest can come either in
person or by soon
second and third second fourth so I
wonder
if we could
try to put some more meat on these bones
and just ship it over to them let's see
what they think you know I mean see if
those numbers shift from 27 up I think
that would be interesting sure yeah it's
it's uh said it's not give them
something concrete rather than just
trying to find a middle ground here that
uh won't uh compromise safety won't
create teacher to burn out won't uh and
just from having work in the infant room
myself for some reason that's the room
when I have to go uh
uh I will say yeah five kids would be a
lot but uh when you've got that second
teacher in there nine doesn't seem so
bad Idaho used to have one to eleven oh
my God
what fire drill how are you gonna do
that oh yeah that that teacher needs to
make sure all the teachers
they're not going to sit down
representation
yeah um so I just know when you Advanced
uh the possibility of changing
all we heard from a lot of providers
like no it
um could you tell us like a little bit
more about how the ratios were developed
and kind of how
sure and again there's there's sort of
this accredited over and above basic
licensing I mean I think there's sort of
this and I think it's safety I
understand that it was really designed
for safety basic licensing is there to
make sure that everyone's safe and well
cared for as opposed to you know
the best optimum care to promote their
Optimum development that's where you
start getting into the license plus and
credit and all that that are doing more
than that so again I believe accredited
programs have a one to three Melissa you
might know
um infant Etc so our licensing is not
the optimum but it's safe
it's safe
safety once again opening
an analogy someone did once before
licensing's purpose really again is
safety if you think of a restaurant you
know they have this sticker in the
kitchen about basic safety but there's a
different system to tell you whether or
not the food tastes good right you know
that's yeah right
other questions for some Philips you
have your hand up or just busy being a
mom it's all right it makes you
something about like working at Child
Care Center I don't even hear like it's
it's like it's just like white noise
just sit there I'm on a conference call
or gin she just hears the back she's
like how do you do that doesn't even
phase me
um
all right I think that's all we have for
you um I know this that was my that was
my own bombshell
um was not wholesale change but
something similar to a Massachusetts
great system with new hampshire-based
ratios
um
anybody else have any um so I'll get you
something in writing you can ship it
over there and we can see if that 27
increases a little bit
um yes we would like to
of course no that's the whole point of
this
debate this out
get told no by a lot of people
well I'm not here to tell you no my name
is Melissa Clement I'm the chief of the
child care licensing unit so
um I wanted to explain what I did with
this chart and what I why I wanted to
present it to the committee
um so essentially
um every time we do a revision we always
look to see what other states are doing
and we particularly focus on the ones
that are around New Hampshire because
those are the ones that our New
Hampshire programs are technically
competing against especially when you're
on the border so we we often look at
Vermont Maine and Massachusetts to see
what they're doing and we evaluate our
regulations based on that as well so the
chart is presented here with all the
different age groups that we have in New
Hampshire and then I listed Vermont
Maine Massachusetts these are all
updated these are all the current ones
that they have the years that are there
the years that they adopted those ratios
Connecticut currently is proposing
something different for one age group
and that's the asterisk there at the end
is the national standards and those I
would I'm assuming they're naus C
standards as well but these are the ones
from caring for our children which is
the comes from the American Academy of
Pediatrics they're kind of the gold
standard of what they believe provides
the optimal learning for children and
when they're being cared for in groups
and then the final column is the most
common in 2020 and this is the most
common by state so what you have here is
if you look at the First Column for the
infants it's a one to four it's the most
common ratio and that's with 33 States
and then their most common group size is
eight and that's in 20 States so that
kind of gives you an overview of the
country along with more detailed about
what's in New England
um I really appreciate that you're
taking a real measured look at this
because as you can imagine every time
ratios come up our hearts kind of go oh
boy what's next
and I can also speak to I was before I
became
um
license working in licensed choke as a
licensing coordinator and working for
DHHS I worked in programs mainly with
infants and toddlers that was my passion
and I did it in Massachusetts and in New
Hampshire so I have a really good
understanding of what the ratios mean in
practice because that these ratios have
been the same this whole time
um working in Massachusetts I can tell
you that it didn't have to do with the
quality of the program I would say the
quality of the programs I worked in a
mass and the ones I worked in New
Hampshire were similar
um as far as how they were operating how
they were run it was so much more
relaxed and better in Massachusetts
because of the one to three or the two
two to seven I can just tell you that's
a completely different atmosphere and
also their group sizes are smaller it's
not just the ratio
it's the number of bodies that you have
in a room that really speaks to what the
children experience I mean I can speak
to staff but I for children if you're
ever worked in an infant classroom you
know that when children one starts
crying there's an automated response and
it goes down the line so now you're
dealing with multiple children who need
things at the same time with potentially
fewer staff to respond and one of the
most
um critical ways that you can have
children especially infants learn is
what they call serve and return where a
child is doing and responding in whether
they're crying making noises cooing
whatever they're doing that they have a
provider there to respond back and that
changes obviously based on the number of
adults that you have in the room
um so those are the things I just wanted
to bring up I've done both and I know
the Massachusetts doing the one to three
two to seven it was immensely better
working in Massachusetts but I was
originally from New Hampshire I came
back because I like the state itself but
the child care working in the child care
was different and I experienced that
firsthand so I just wanted to share that
as well and toddlers you know they don't
stop moving so if you anytime you juggle
that and you have you know more kids
with fewer staff it it just it's going
to become that much more difficult than
I am worried about our Workforce
in again this is personal experience in
my early 20s I worked with mainly
one-year-olds and two-year-olds
um that is the time of your life when
you have the most energy I wasn't
married I didn't have kids
um I would have friends that would
request that hey it's Friday night let's
go out I was like I'm going to be asleep
by 7 30. I have been working with these
one and two-year-olds all week I don't
have the energy for that so anytime
you're trying to add more children with
fewer staff I can imagine that there
will be an impact it's harder to
quantify it's more of a qualitative
experience it's really harder to
quantify but I wanted to express that as
well of course and we have to balance
that with the impact of people not being
able to find Child Care nope right we
really understand it we've heard about
how teachers don't get paid enough this
is an opportunity to increase cash flow
through the center right so this is a
balancing act
um and that's you know that's that's one
of the reasons I thought we had to have
the conversation is we often when it
comes to ratios we look at the overwhelm
the negative of increasing it the
negatives are obvious but we often
Overlook the positives which is
increased teacher pay increase access to
child care supply you increase access to
child care supply and providers also
have to start competing for for parents
again when they have to start paying
appearance again they start enrolling in
things like the grand steps for Quality
right and then we start bringing some
Market balance back
um
but it's it's obvious it's a
conversation that has to take place in
good faith with open minds
um
so that they appreciate that
I mean what this chart was and to give
you some well you've saved me from
having to do some work because you got
the Massachusetts numbers that already
so I guess yeah
thank you very much anyone else wants to
comment on the totally Kumbaya subject
of ratios
yes
part I will be speaking as the executive
director at Merrimack Valley daycare
service so my knee to reaction is
definitely to not increase ratios but
your argument is compelling and the way
that I could actually see myself doing
this is average daily attendance so
anyone who works in child care knows the
only way you can ever make any money is
to keep your average daily attendance at
a certain amount but no one attends
every day I mean it's rare to have a
person who comes every day and so the
ability to over enroll slightly so your
average daily attendance is correct is a
great way to stay economically helpful
uh healthy so I can see this as being a
benefit for your average daily
attendance and if you slightly over
enroll for an infant room and you're
over by one child one day a week or
something it's okay you're still within
your ratio to do so so I just want to
say that it's possible that maybe this
is something that can move forward with
some caveats attached to it so you
literally have to literally have I
thought about it it was was I've never
seen I never see eight kids in my infant
room God I'd love to enroll nine but
what happens if they're all here on the
same day
any other questions comments concerns
and wait by the way we will come back to
this so don't I don't think this is the
end I'll be all this just opening Salvo
yes Miss Clement
thank you again my apologies I just
remembered one other thing any change
that we have to do will have to run by
the State Fire Marshal's office as well
they have State Fire codes that are
actually more strict than our child care
licensing rules but we are able to
operate under our rules with the
variance from them so if we change
anything we have to run it by them as
well to get there we've never talked
about fire codes
I just want to say that that's part of
that would have to be part of the
conversation I think I wrote I think I
wrote an amendment specifically about
that and then the other
um it was something that came up when
you were discussing the gsq
um representative Barry I heard you say
during testimony that A Lead Teacher is
required in every classroom and that's
actually not accurate so I wanted to
make sure that that was clear as well
it's required when there's three or more
teachers based on the group size but
it's not required in every classroom
that's true that's true I I do think I'm
from the perspective of my own Center so
yes that's it admittedly a bias
thank you
um anything else
all right well with that
um not probably not going to meet next
week just kind of bring it from a fire
hose right now
um with other things
um I I kind of outlined the beginning
what our next two meetings will be about
um the be our final two work session
meetings here in Concord one more
meeting um in the field possibly one
more after that uh and then uh uh MJ I'm
sorry representative Waller I apologize
um the informality
um my goal is to meet again after those
let's say the next three meetings
um would be to meet once or twice before
Bill filing so we could let's say uh
finish our work
um and come to consensus just so you
know as the ranking member how dare you
how dare you I will hold it against you
forever yes representative page
something else I'm curious about and I'd
love to have someone speak to at a
future meeting is on the use of the uh
remaining arpa dollars
um
because just seeing how
how the the plan for expending those
remaining dollars there's a lot of
interesting things there
um and I'd like to think I'd like to
think about how we as a committee might
piggyback and on that work and sustain
it you know My worry is there's this one
shot of this Russia Federal funding
we're suddenly going to spend it before
the deadline hits
um you know and I want to make sure that
that that that that work doesn't just
you know wither because there's no plan
for sustaining it beyond the beyond the
year so I'd love to hear more about the
plan for expanding those funds see what
we can do
um our money always gives me a heartburn
so it's okay
all right uh with that we will close
this up thank you all for being here I
thought I thought it was going to be
quick turns I've been around for two
minutes so
um I appreciate it uh see you guys when
I see you guys
I'm gonna get you your reports
foreign